I just got home from the gym,
and I'm hiding in my office
because I don't want my kids to hear what I'm about to talk about.
We have a massive problem in this country,
and I can't believe I'm on here talking about another school shooting
literally three weeks into the school year.
But we have another young boy who had access to guns,
who was gifted a gun by his parents,
who already had made threats against a school,
who had already shown aggressive behavior,
who actually followed through with his threats.
I've been following Mom's demand action for years,
and this happens more than it makes national news.
It happens all the fucking time.
And everyone who is pro gun,
and I'm not gonna say pro second Amendment,
because there are responsible gun owners,
people who are just pro gun without any registration,
any background checks, any sort of incumbencies to owning a weapon.
Those people constantly say that it's not a gun issue,
it's a mental health issue.
It's a people issue. Okay,
then what the fuck are we doing for our boys?
What are we doing for our sons?
Our white sons? What are we doing for them?
What are we doing for our schools?
Used to be super against, like,
metal detectors and SROs, but now it seems like,
almost insane that we don't have those,
because we refuse to do anything about the core problem,
and we refuse to do anything other than Like gun drills for our kids
and. And this just keeps happening.
And the people who are super pro gun
are exactly the type of people who are gonna turn to their boys
and tell them to suck it up
and stop being a sissy and act like a man.
And we're shocked. And we're shocked we have an aggression issue.
We don't let boys feel feelings.
We give them first person shooter games,
we give them rifles as 14 year old holiday presents.
And then we're shocked when these emotionally unintelligent,
emotionally under developed boys with an entitlement complex
because they're white boys,
white men, they should be getting everything on a fucking platter.
And when life doesn't go their way,
who are they gonna blame? Their classmates?
Their mean teachers? The girls who laugh at them?
And that's who gets their violence.
That's who gets their violence.
This issue is bigger than guns,
but that's one of the major issues.
And if we don't address any of the major issues
contributing to the epidemic of gun violence in our schools,
then we are literally wiping our hands up the problem
and saying thoughts and prayers.
And I don't know about you,
but I'm fucking sick of thoughts and prayers.
They haven't changed a fucking thing.
Not one thing. They haven't comforted one family,
they haven't prevented one shooting. None.
Zero, zero percent success rate with thoughts and prayers.
Maybe it's time to start talking about comprehensive mental health.
Talk about breaking the cycle of toxic
masculine suppression of feelings.
talk about the impact of isolation and first person shooter games.
You know, changing what we're doing with these boys.
Isn't it worth trying? Isn't it worth just trying something different?
It is insanity to watch this happen over and over again
and do absolutely fuck all to address any of the underlying issues.
Insanity.